good evening and welcome to Olsen's
books and records at Courthouse tonight
we are very pleased to have with us mr.
Steve Cole author of ghost wars books on
giddy oil and also a book about journeys
throughout Southeast Asia currently
isn't one of the editors of The
Washington Post and Pulitzer
prize-winning author and we are very
very pleased to have him with us tonight
to discuss ghost wars and the new
updated paperback version welcome mr.
Cole thank you thank you Maria Christina
and thank you all for coming out tonight
a better tilt this we have c-span with
us so when it turns to questions don't
say anything you don't want America to
hear and I'm actually looking forward to
their question and answer discussion and
I'm not going to monopolize the time for
too long but I thought I would introduce
the paper back a little bit and give
those of you who haven't spent much time
with the book a sense of where it came
from and what it's about and some of the
themes in it it's a product of my own
experience as a correspondent overseas
for the post I was based in New Delhi
for three years between 1989 and 1992
and during that time I spent a lot of
time in Afghanistan after that tour I
was assigned to London where I worked on
transnational subjects for three years
between 1992 and 1995 primarily nuclear
proliferation but also the rise of Sunni
Islamic radicalism in the Middle East
and so I was working on bin Laden in
those years along with a lot of other
subjects I think on September 11th I had
the same experience that a lot of South
Asia specialists had which was along
with shock and revulsion a sense of
amazement that this place Afghanistan
and those who had found sanctuary there
had come suddenly crashing into the
center of American affairs because to be
a South Asia specialist in the years
that I was working on that subject was
to labor in a fairly obscure corner of
the world and an obscure field I think
that was true inside the government as
well as for journalists most of the
glory went to the Russia hands and the
China hands and those who specialized in
the arab-israeli conflict and my
ambition after September 11th was to try
to write a history that would locate the
antecedents of the attacks in
Afghanistan where after all they did
arise from and so my ambition was to
write a narrative history for an
American audience about the roots of
September 11th as they were located in
Afghanistan as they were located in
American engagements in Afghanistan and
to try to draw a thread from the moment
of the Soviet invasion through to the
moment of the attacks and to do that in
a comprehensive way so that was the
project and I'll come back a little bit
to some of the broader themes before we
turn to your questions just to explain
the paperback which comes out now a year
after the book was originally published
of course the 9/11 Commission did its
work between the time that I brought the
book out and and the time that I had to
prepare a paperback edition and so my
goal in this particular edition was to
try to improve the book by taking
advantage of the disclosures that the
9/11 Commission's investigators had made
for me this meant primarily taking
advantage of all of the documents that
they put onto the record particularly
about the last couple or three years
before September 11th so this is not an
edition that is merely added to it
doesn't just have an afterword I
actually wrote through it in a sense and
integrated into the text new materials
from the 9/11 Commission
that work involved not a massive
revision but it did involve significant
adjustments and additions primarily to
the last part of the book which which
covers sorry I would say by less than 5%
in a in a mathematical sense but what
essentially I was rewarded to discover
that the 9/11 Commission did not
disclose episodes in this narrative that
I wasn't more or less aware of there
what they did was to bring forward quite
a lot of detail in nuance and
understanding that I didn't have in
particularly documents they they made
profound new disclosures that I didn't
that didn't touch my narrative I think
principally about the 9/11 attack itself
where it came from how it originated and
they I think profoundly revised our
understanding of the attackers and their
plot but as to the narrative of American
foreign policy and intelligence policy
which is my primary focus here there
were I think subtler additions that they
offered to the record and I tried to
incorporate those because I wanted the
narrative to be as accurate and and sort
of complete as I could as I could make
it so that was my purpose with the
paperback it's difficult in 10 or 15
minutes to summarize a narrative of this
length and complexity and so I'm not
really going to attempt that but I would
like just as a perhaps as a stimulus to
our discussion that arises from your
questions to draw out a few themes and
threads that I think are at least as I
look back on my own research part of
what I've enjoyed about going on and
trying to talk about the book is that
it's helped me think about its themes
and even analyze my own reporting
to a greater degree than I was able to
do while I was assembling the history
itself and also I'm interested as I'm
sure you are in what the relationship
between past and present and present is
about and I think there are some themes
among the many in the history that speak
with particular force to the to the
present and to all of the unfinished
business that's that surrounds us I
organized this narrative into three
parts because I think the history
organizes itself into three chapters the
first is the period of the anti Soviet
war in Afghanistan from the time of the
invasion to the time of the Soviet
withdrawal in 1989 the second is the
period after the Soviets left and as we
decided to withdraw from Afghanistan how
that vacuum was created how it was
filled by the Taliban and what the
Afghanistan was that a sum of in Laden
returned to in the spring of 1996 when
he was forced out of Sudan and brought
his multinational army its back to
Afghanistan
and then the third episode is the effort
by the United States to confront bin
Laden before September 11th on on Afghan
ground the period in which the CIA among
in the lead was authorized to return to
Afghanistan this time for the purpose of
capturing or killing bin Laden
disrupting al-qaeda and its leadership
and so the third part of the narrative
is about how that effort was undertaken
and why it failed to prevent September
11th
let me just tease out several themes
from those three sort of phases and
particularly those that I think are
still alive today in some respect I
think one of the most important aspects
of the anti-soviet jihad that the United
States along with the Pakistan Army and
the Saudi government funded and supplied
was the way the politics of that effort
was organized and managed and the
reasons for that approach in particular
the United States decided to subcontract
the politics of the anti-soviet war to
Pakistan this was I think a self
conscious decision that those involved
in the program made they made it because
they believe first that the United
States had really only one overriding
interest in participating in this jihad
in the first place which was to
challenge and and to defeat the Soviet
Union to raise the costs of the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan and then later
in the eighties when it became possible
to believe in such things to actually
reverse the invasion and in the course
of pursuing that goal there was a sense
that it would be a mistake to
concentrate to divert attention to the
complexities of regional politics and
regional ideology this was a generation
of CIA officers recently scarred by
their experiences in Vietnam who
essentially declared no more hearts and
minds for us we're terrible at picking
winners and losers in the developing
world as our recent record shows we have
no interest in attempting such a thing
in Pakistan and Afghanistan a place that
didn't exactly reward the British for
such efforts and the Pakistanis if they
have an interest in promoting Muslim
Brotherhood influenced Sunni radical
Islam as a mechanism for controlling
Afghanistan and unruly neighbor to their
West if that's their interest in the war
so be it we have only one interest that
justifies our involvement here and
that's
to challenge the Soviet Union and so
there was a deliberate and sustained
policy of standing back from the Afghan
nests of the war as it were and a
willingness to let the Pakistanis decide
who benefited as the war went along and
I think it's interesting to reflect on
this and certainly to reflect on it in
context because I've tried to articulate
it just there as in the most defensible
way because I think it isn't he on its
face a bizarre approach to the
anti-soviet period but I think what
becomes interesting is that as the 80s
move along and as it finally becomes
clear but the Soviets are really going
to leave that they that Gorbachev means
what he says that he is going to with
withdraw and the Soviets begin to
demonstrate on the ground that they
intend to leave that this approach of
managing Afghanistan through the
Pakistan Army and through the Pakistan
Army's agenda is essentially never
re-examined or if it's reexamined it's
debated and a view prevails that even in
the absence of the Soviet Union's 40th
army in Afghanistan we have no interests
sufficient to justify the risks and
uncertainties of getting involved in
reconstruction reconstructing
Afghanistan in building centrist
politics in isolating the extremists who
had benefited from the war and in trying
to reassemble the rubble that the war
had created physical and human by the
time the United States decided to
withdraw entirely from Afghanistan to
end the covered action program on
January 1 1992 and to withdraw even from
humanitarian aid projects in Afghanistan
which was effectively decided by 1993 or
1994 there was a sense in Washington
that Afghanistan was an intractable
problem one that didn't involve vital
American interests and that again if the
Pakistan Army wanted to promote radical
Islamic clients as a way of trying to
solve this mess that was that might be
in their interest but it
wasn't no business of ours and so in
this vacuum that the United States left
as it withdrew eventually the Taliban
relish and I think that's just the third
theme that I would try to tease out
before we turn to your questions which
is this question of trying to decide who
is your adversary and why are they your
adversaries very I found it fascinating
to go back on the history of American
foreign policy in the mid-1990s and
discover how few Americans or for that
matter Europeans really understood the
Taliban as a serious adversary of the
United States its interest its values
really to be fair only the feminists
understood the Taliban is a totalitarian
movement just about everybody else
involved in the discussion wanted to
explain them as a force for stability as
a force that would moderate as a
movement that was rooted in Afghan
social and cultural traditions which was
simply not the case as their rapid
collapse
I think demonstrated and most of all to
avoid the fact that the Taliban really
were an instrument of Pakistani policy
that really I don't think it's possible
to understand the Taliban's claims on
national power in Afghanistan without
understanding them as a proxy force of
the Pakistan Army and indirectly of the
Saudi government and the Pakistanis in
the Saudi is both the secular
politicians in Pakistan and the army as
well as the Saudi government continually
argued to the United States look these
guys may seem medieval to you but they
are rooted in socially conservative
traditions in southern Afghanistan and
they will moderate they will become
normal if you just engage with them they
will grow the Saudis in particular said
again and again we were a little bit
like this at the beginning the beginning
of the century
you know a little bit immature as a
socially and religiously conservative
movement and as we modernized well the
edge came off that's arguable I suppose
but what's interesting about this this
conversation which occurred largely out
of public earshot I think was not so
much that these arguments were
ultimately persuasive to Americans
involved in them but that there was no
will to think otherwise that there was
no context to think otherwise in the end
I guess what I'm driving at is that I
think as a as a country we have had a
lot of conversation about the extent to
which and the way in which September
11th was a failure of intelligence or a
failure of tactical covert operations
against bin Laden a failure of policing
a failure of government organization but
we've had quite a lot less conversation
about the extent to which September 11th
was a failure of foreign policy there's
a lot of that observation that we could
chew on but I would just finish with
this idea that I began with myself in
this work which is Afghanistan itself
when the CIA was authorized after 1998
to try to capture or kill bin Laden
disrupt al-qaeda leadership in
Afghanistan all of the iterations of
that effort were undertaken without ever
trying to confront bin Laden in his
Afghan context these were what Amit Shah
Massoud is intelligence aides who were
sometimes involved in the effort called
Hollywood operations they were meant to
pluck bin Laden out of Afghanistan
without ever choosing sides in the civil
war that the Taliban was waging without
ever confronting Afghanistan's
humanitarian crisis one of the worst in
the world without ever attempting to
visualize a stable or modernizing
Afghanistan that was regarded as an
impossible project instead this was a
police action with a very small number
of enemies whose names could appear on a
list
and it was hoped that they could be
plucked off of this failed States ground
without bothering the failed state
indeed one of the iterations of
instructions that were given to CIA
officers involved in this effort and who
were liaison with the Northern Alliance
before that phrase that name was
familiar to many Americans involved
providing the Northern Alliance with
technical equipment and other support
that might help locate bin Laden as he
was hiding in Afghanistan and the
instructions said that the officers
engaged in this liaison could take no
action that would fundamentally alter
the Afghan battlefield now you can
imagine this group the Northern Alliance
they were in an existential war against
the Taliban and al Qaeda along the
Front's north of Kabul they were dealing
with opponents who were willing to take
their own lives in the course of battle
and we were providing the Northern
Alliance with modest technical equipment
and if you were delivering that
equipment you were legally obliged to
decide whether or not by providing this
or that you might fundamentally alter
the Afghan battlefield you could alter
it but not fundamentally so I guess it's
sort of like the Star Trek prime
directive and how you explain a moment
like that an American engagement or half
engagement in Afghanistan I think is you
can only reach that explanation by going
back to foreign policy and the broad
contextual failure to see what
Afghanistan was and why bin Laden
thrived there so thank you for listening
and let's let's have a discussion based
on on your questions
recently the military which receives
about 80% of the intelligence budget has
been used to gather intelligence more so
than the CIA so what I'm wondering is
back then when we were involved so much
with Afghanistan people was there a
conflict between the militaries
gathering of intelligence and the CIA
and did the military have any influence
on our foreign policy well they did have
influence the everyone here or some
version of the question the question was
referring to the recent stories in the
paper about the Pentagon's efforts to
ramp up it's particularly its human
intelligence apparatus and its
collection that and the question was in
those days back in the late 90s was
there a conflict between the CIA and the
Pentagon over operations in Afghanistan
and did the Pentagon have a role in
America in the foreign policy and the
answer is that I think in those days in
that period between 1998 and 2001 it was
really only the CIA that was active in
Afghanistan the Pentagon wanted nothing
to do with the problem of a ground or
other attack in Afghanistan against bin
Laden and repeated efforts to try to
draw a Special Operations Command into
the effort were met with a lack of
enthusiasm certainly at the senior
levels I think down in the sort of mid
levels there was an appetite to
participate but none of the leadership
of either the civilian or uniformed side
of the Pentagon believed that there was
a plausible path to attacking bin Laden
or al-qaeda leadership in Afghanistan
before September 11th and so they were
actually quite I think content to let
the CIA take the lead in those days it's
interesting if you try to discover the
origins of
this parent reported push by secretary
Rumsfeld for an independent intelligence
capability at the Pentagon I think you
really have to go back to the fall of
2001 when it was the ability of the
CIA's counter-terrorist Center to offer
a plausible plan of action in the
immediate aftermath of the attacks that
it had the relationships in northern
Afghanistan with the Northern Alliance
it had the history and a it had been
operating
however sporadically in the region and
so they were able to put their people on
the ground in Afghanistan before the art
before the Pentagon could get organized
and that really annoyed Rumsfeld I think
Bart's piece even quoted a memo
essentially sort of in a Fountainhead
memo that in which runs field said why
the is it only the CIA that is on the
ground here a month or six weeks after
the attacks and he wanted to be in a
position to put either uniformed or
other Pentagon folks in the lead at a
moment like that
said in the mid-90s the discussion was
left largely out of the public earshot
and as a journalist can you comment on
possibly a failure in the American press
to
address some of these topics for example
how many other American foreign
correspondents we're in South Asia over
there yeah and I think the media failed
I think we all failed I feel no pride
about that record there are as some
corners of the government can point to
there are pockets of things you could be
proud of there certainly was good
journalism about Afghanistan and its
collapse about the humanitarian crisis
about the nature of the Taliban about
the nature of the repression in
Afghanistan and both post in the New
York Times I think did work that really
holds up in retrospect about al Qaeda
and bin Laden I think we did less well
you know the The Times had a pretty
oppression package of stories at one
point early in 2001 but the kind of
sustained coverage of what al Qaeda had
become what kind of sanctuary had
enjoyed what kind of organization it was
how its leadership worked what its
ambitions were and particularly to focus
on the most distinctive act aspect of al
Qaeda and and bin Laden's leadership of
al Qaeda which was the pursuit of mass
casualty attacks in the United States
that bin Laden really did mean what he
said and that he had the means to carry
it out because you know bin Laden is
really quite different from many other
terrorist leaders of his kind in the
last 30 or 40 years in the sense that he
hasn't spent his career skulking from
safe house to safe house he has lived
more or less in the open and has spoken
and written repeatedly about his aims
and in the case of his desire to take
large numbers of civilian casualties on
American soil he had made that ambition
quite plain and had really spoken and
written about it with some nuance but I
don't think a sustained viewing of
American television network news or even
really a sustained reading of even the
best American newspapers would have
provided an adequate account of his
ambitions somebody else has a question
yes likely Pakistan's policy would
change in the future when and if Sharif
either steps down or is killed we've
seen a lot of conflicting things between
their initial relationship to more
recently taking a strong line and it's
unclear which forces in Pakistan seem to
be more dominant which how do you think
of what the future will say towards that
well it's a good question I think that
it's a in some respects it's an
important mystery that is alive in the
American partnership with Pakistan you
know I would say in the three years and
however many months in September 11th
that Pakistan clearly has changed its
approach to Afghanistan and I was
skeptical for reasons that I'll explain
about how full that commitment was and
still think that there are questions to
be asked and monitored there but to me a
an important turning point was the
presidential election last night last
autumn when the Taliban failed to make
an impact they really didn't show up and
they had threatened to disrupt the
elections violently and they had
suggested through violence through the
spring and summer that they might have
the potential to really take a lot of
Afghan line
lives ordinary Afghans standing in line
to to vote in this election and I think
that there was a question about whether
Pakistan wanted to continue to use the
Taliban as a source of pressure on
Karzai in the United States and his
ethnic Taj Akande who's back allies as a
kind of whole car not fully disrupt
Afghan politics but make plain the
potency of a revived Taliban did was
that an intention I think that the
Pakistan
government an army did demonstrate in
2004 that they'd really broken with that
policy at least for now and I think that
that was a real breakthrough for
Afghanistan and an important reason why
the election succeeded in they they did
succeed I think there is still a way in
a very complicated way that Pakistan is
holding the idea of the Taliban and the
idea of cross-border jihad in reserve as
a potential instrument of the sort that
they have used for 20 years previously
in reserve against one against the day
when they fear as in the past the United
States will lose interest in the region
and withdraw and they will be left to
contest with India on their own in an
inferior structural position and for
them the jihadis have always been the
winning weapon against India they're not
an instrument against the United States
for Pakistan there are a way to
challenge their much larger enemy next
door and when the Pakistanis discovered
during the 1990s that a handful of
jihadi is relatively speaking could tie
down two hundred four hundred five
hundred thousand Indian troops in
Kashmir just by getting them excited and
sending them across the border with
enough cash and guns to wreak havoc they
discovered that really jihadism was for
Pakistan's long unfinished contest with
India potentially more effective and
more practical strategic weapon than
even a nuclear deterrent and I think
that they there are certainly elements
of the Pakistani intelligent that have
not given up on that idea
visa via India now they are prepared for
another way there is this space that
were in now it's the space in which
India and Pakistan are trying to
negotiate a it not I don't think a final
settlement anytime in the next couple or
three years but a more sustainable peace
an interregnum and
Pakistan really did prove in the in 2004
that they were not going to openly
support the strategies and tactics of
proxy Islamist forces in Afghanistan
that they'd pursued for so long just to
complete the thought without getting
into too much complexity part of the
trouble is that the Pakistan provinces
that border Afghanistan the Northwest
Frontier Province and Balochistan
and not to mention the federally
administered tribal areas where bin
Laden is presumed to be hiding these
essentially uncovered agencies up on the
border those provinces are now
controlled by Islamist religious parties
that were brought to power an election
supervised by the Pakistan Army and I
joke with my Pakistani friends that I
can't really tell whether the the
success of the religious parties along
the frontier was a mistake or a strategy
and and this is something that
Pakistanis themselves debate you know
some people insist that it was not the
result Musharraf wanted skeptics cynics
say well it's a useful form of this
reserve play this kind of reserve
against another day in any event it may
be something that he has trouble it's
certainly something that he has trouble
managing today
the week of December and Tarkio
Fussell's
grave and ultimately successful libel
award for damages in UK against Laurel
more ogwuche yes really formally LaRue
she who was disowned by the RAND
Corporation and the episode here but it
was French publication press and so on
and he donated his damages to Islamic
Relief to the people of Afghanistan
would you hear now that you've been
through your own book twice to sort of
put the Saudi involvement which was
originally instead of a fifty fifty
dollar involvement with the US in
hindsight for us sure I mean Prince
Turkey as you know he's a sort of a
character in this narrative and so I've
tried to describe as carefully and fully
as I can in the book what it is that I
know but to try to summarize that at
your invitation you're right the first
part the first phase is a partnership
between the United States and Saudi
Arabia was essentially a check-writing
deal in at least as far as the American
partnership with the Saudi government
was concerned when the United States
Congress under findings signed by
successive presidents began to allocate
funds for the covert action program
against the Soviets in Afghanistan then
CIA director or the director of Central
Intelligence bill Casey went to Saudi
Arabia and enlisted the commitment of
then King Fahd to well I guess it was
first Khalid and then fadh2 right
matching checks for the American
allocation so whatever it was determined
what the congressional allocation would
be the Saudis would write a matching
check dollar to dollar and that money
would be pooled and managed through the
Pakistan army to support the jihad and
that was the principal official channel
of US and Saudi support for the
anti-soviet jihad
however the Saudis had
their own separate unilateral operations
run through charities run through their
own intelligence service this to involve
more check writing than operating but it
did involve an aspect of their presence
on the frontier that was outside of the
American partnership and the American
Channel well it involved building
religious schools it involves supporting
Wahhabi charities it involved eventually
working directly with representatives
like Osama bin Laden to build military
facilities and other logistical support
for Saudi clients on the frontier
particularly clients like Jalal Edina
Connie who's still a an important
Taliban flagged fugitive in Afghanistan
and who some people speculate may be one
source of osama's current refuge and
when i part of what I try to describe is
exactly what osama's relationship with
Saudi intelligence was in these years
and I did interview Saudi prince
Turkey's principal chief of staff in
these years I'm and 'buddy be and his
the head of the Saudi equivalent of the
Directorate of intelligence the
analytical wing of the intelligence
department who was I'm Abbott's brother
and and Syed but even they did have
connections with Osama in those days
they everybody was sort of more or less
swimming in the same direction but
Osama's work was in the what I would
characterize as the Saudi unilateral
channel that I think one of the more
interesting mysteries and you know I
sort of feel like I have a something of
an outline understanding of Saudi work
in the 80s I think the Saudi
government's relationship with the
Taliban in the 1990s is a is still an
important mystery and in some respects
there were similar there was a similar
diversity of channels by which the Saudi
is engaged with the Taliban the Saudi
Ministry of the religious police's
that's commonly call
the ministry for the Prevention of Vice
and the propagation or virtue you know
they they had one channel with the
Taliban and and then the foreign
ministry and Prince Turkey had other
channels and so forth there's a lot
about that period that we don't that we
don't know you said that if I heard you
correctly you thought that the past was
relevant to the present and I hear that
as well there are lessons to be learned
here and applied now are the foreign
policy establishment here learning those
lessons and applying them well I think
some of them as to Afghanistan certainly
the American commitment to
reconstruction stability and centrist
politics is pretty thorough going
whether it's sustainable or not or not I
think is a question about which it's
difficult to be confident I think that
the areas where the lessons feel less
fully baked involved alliances with
Pakistan and Saudi Arabia in particular
even if you take the most hard-headed
frame for evaluating American
partnership with the Pakistan Army you
have to observe that while we have come
very close together since September 11th
both in terms of operating against
al-qaeda leaders in Pakistan and along
the border in partnership on the
reconstruction of Afghanistan
and through the provision of multi
billion dollars worth of military
hardware and aid to the Pakistan Army
that this partnership is still involves
two governments with very different
interests in the partnership and I think
that there's one of the I would be
interested in other people's reactions
of this but one of my own reactions to
the full narrative of the liaison
between the United States and Pakistan
particularly the collaboration between
the CIA and ISI
but it speaks to the larger relationship
as well is that inevitably and any of
you have worked in government or in
bureaucracy know how this happens
there's a certain momentum of liaison
that builds up so that the liaison just
exists to justify itself and it becomes
very difficult to break out of the
assumptions of the partnership however
poisonous they may at a certain stage
become and find the eyesight the vision
and the courage to act in your own
interests and I think the Pakistanis
because they feel they have a lot on the
line the existence of their nation-state
have tended to be a little more ruthless
in that respect and whether or not the
public celebration of the unblemished
unmitigated ly successful partnership
that is now allegedly enjoyed between
the government of United States the
government of Pakistan is privately seen
with a more realistic set of eyes is
difficult for me to be confident about I
presume that all of the public
celebration that the partnership is
couldn't be better this I think we post
have an interview with the president
recently in which we were asking about
why he thought sama bin Laden hadn't
been captured and his first line was
because he's hiding yeah and then the
second follow-up question was something
effective well do you think your
partners are as fully engaged in this as
they should be and he said I can't think
of a single Alliance involved in this
hunt where where there's a single flaw
in the Alliance our partners are
absolutely great and you know now that's
the sort of thing you might say in order
to keep a shaky partnership organized
but I presume it's not actually what
anybody believes what's what's more
interesting is the complicated question
of how the divergent interest of the
Pakistan Army and the United States and
the hunt for bin Laden can be
successfully managed because the
Pakistan Army's concern in the search
for bin Laden is not that his capture
will bring the house tumbling down or
that they can't stand the political heat
or other things that are occasionally
speculated about in
my view in my sense of things from
talking to those involved on the
Pakistani side they're concerned it's
quite reasonable if you sit in their
shoes is that as soon as bin Laden and
Safari are in custody the United States
is going to go home and or tilt to India
quite dramatically and that basically
this is the pattern of American
partnership that as soon as the
Americans have what they came to South
Asia for they either go home or they
turn and support our enemies and really
from a Pakistani point of view this is
not an unreasonable reading of history
in 1971 you know we let the country be
dismembered after the anti-soviet war we
walked away in fact we didn't just walk
away we slap press on Iran in an edition
and get in mothballed their f-16s so if
you're sitting in their shoes and you
and you're asking what's gonna happen
when bin Laden is wearing stripe you
know prison suits and and there's nobody
left on the frontier to worry about and
especially with all of the momentum and
the natural strategic partnership
between the United States and India
that's building up which is sort of
undeniable well you know how do you
manage that insecurity in the
relationship without creating an
environment in which somehow the
Pakistan army does not do 150 percent of
what it's possible to do to actually
bring bin Laden Zawahiri to justice
because really Musharraf I think after
two assassination attempts is
persuadable on the point that al Qaeda
is is a mortal enemy of the state of
Pakistan as well as of the United States
and I'm not suggesting that they're
harboring bin Laden but but have we
really worked out enough mutual
confidence to ensure that every effort
that could be made will be made I don't
know
Pakistan are run by individuals who have
an extremist religious view given the
present situation in Pakistan
what are the trends of these religious
goal survey
Aransas are influential
they're fewer in number well there have
been some notional educational reforms
in Pakistan since September 11th there
their effect on the ground I think has
been so far around the margins
I think the religious schools the
madrasahs are important but I'm not sure
that they are as central to the problem
of mass casualty jihadism as sometimes
our discussions make them if you
carefully analyze who the most dangerous
jihadis are they are not by and large
products of the madrasas where which are
really sort of catchments for the
disenfranchised in Pakistan now the
Taliban leadership did emerge from
deobandi madrasahs and particularly a
dangerous one east of a shower but many
of the attackers that have carried out
the most violent assaults on American
and Western interests are alienated
english-medium educated technically
educated middle class radicals who like
many other kinds of leftist radicals and
other radicals before them appear to
have been radicalized as part of their
unfinished engagement with Western
education Western systems so who today
are the most dangerous jihadis in the
movement that al-qaeda now aspires to
lead since it's no longer really an
organization the organization has been
smashed but it's left behind a movement
that's very broadly distributed and you
know I think a lot of them answer to
that question for instance lies in in
Europe where you have second and third
generation young Muslim men who
have been unable to integrate into
European societies that haven't had the
success with integrating immigrant
communities and establishing a broad
pluralism that the United States for all
of its flaws has had and I think also if
you look at just the Homburg cell or the
Madrid cell or you know pick a cell
basically and you analyze the
educational roots of the most violent
radicals in that group you end up in
technical schools speaking English not
in them in the madrasas in many in many
cases anybody else somebody else what do
I think would be the political military
consequences of Musharraf being
assassinated tomorrow I think that they
would not be immediately severe I think
that the corps commander group around
Musharraf at the top of the Pakistan
Army is like-minded that it is
disciplined and that it has already
thought through the possibility of
Musharraf disappearance with with good
reason and that the army leadership on
the whole believes that the interests of
the army are served by broad-brush are
served by the policies that Musharraf
has pursued and I think they're right
about that the interest the army has
been well rewarded on the whole for the
policies that Musharraf has pursued
there could well be nuanced differences
in the management of those policies by a
particular successor of Musharraf and
the history of army chiefs in Pakistan
is one of occasional wild cards Aslam
bag for instance in the early 1990s we
now understand to be one of the root
collaborators with Iran on nuclear
matters sometimes these guys come up the
chain and they sort of break out of the
of the policy consensus that the court
commanders have been operating with
where they twisted and turn it in a new
direction so you can't rule that out but
I think essentially what Musharraf
represents is a particularly fluent
general in western idioms who is
nonetheless representing a consensus
among his disciplined senior leadership
in the army I think that actually the
issue in Pakistan in the medium run is
not the lack of a consensus among the
senior uniformed generals about the
broad outline of policies now being
pursued but whether or not the army with
creative American and Indian
collaboration will learn to share power
and by sharing power strengthening
strength in the country and even
strengthen itself as an institution this
is the real trick and and I don't know
how good Musharraf is at that trick like
a lot of despots he's become enamored of
his own position and you can feel that
in the way that he interacts with people
but at the same time he's looking for a
way to broaden the political base that
the army operates in he's trying now to
draw the Pakistan Peoples Party back in
to politics that would be a good thing
if he could figure out a way to do it
but he doesn't want to actually share a
power with the Pakistani people parties
leaders and so that becomes a hard
objective to achieve and you know there
have been some generals in Pakistan's
history that have been better at
domestic politics than others and I
think that more than a consensus within
the corps commander group is the
challenge that Musharraf now faces he
has to rise to a different kind of
politics and succeed and I think that he
has to do that for the Army's sake but
also for for Pakistan's sake
got the new
Kwasi democratically-elected Karzai
government is this the spearmint such an
Islamic country
feasible is you see this working in the
long term or once the United States
pulls out you see this as being
something that you know was a small
chapter in Afghan history and that's it
what are how do we think about the
Karzai government and its longevity its
dependence on the United States what's
the nature of this experiment I think
that it is a not an aberration entirely
in Afghan history that it's a tentative
and in many ways hopeful restoration of
an extension of the centrist Afghan
politics that were present in the long
period of peace between 1930 and 1970
and that Karzai's success while
inseparable from American support now
and for the foreseeable future is not
rooted solely in his partnership with
the United States and the international
community it is also very profoundly
rooted in Afghan politics and the desire
after 20 years of shattering war of
afghans of many stripes to construct a
different kind of politics and a
different nation and i think that the
dog that didn't bark in afghanistan over
the last three years has had opportunity
to bark a number of times and has stood
down Fahim the thuggish defense minister
and intelligence chief and partner of
Amit Shah Massoud who locked out of the
spoils of the cabinet accepted his fate
without trying to organize a coup d'etat
kanuni another disappointed member of
the cabinet decides to start a political
party and not to point a tank barrel at
his adversaries
dustin ismail khan made the poster boy
of the warlords who have to go he
accepts Ministry of Mines and energy or
whatever it is he's got now you know
good for him
it's probably a pretty lucrative
ministry as these things go not to cast
dispersions on his integrity but i mean
it's a it's a you know it's the kind of
normalization of politics that's
essential if this is gonna stick and
it's happening it's happening not
because the Americans want it to happen
it's happening because Afghans are
making this decision time and again why
did the Taliban not turn up in November
yes the United States delivered the
security regime with the resources it
had that was necessary yes so did NATO
and the United Nations and others
collaborated successfully on the role
that Outsiders could play but the
Taliban didn't show up because ordinary
Pashtun has made it impossible for them
to operate ordinary Pashtun x'
essentially rejected the Taliban as a
vehicle for Pashtun aspirations what's
what's the most unfinished business in
this respect its Pashtun politics if
Afghanistan can organize over the next
five to ten years with the space that
the international community's and
American policy creates ordinary Pashtun
politics that resembles the
decision-making are referred to in the
Northern Alliance which was a mature
political movement in a sense then I
really then there's really hope right
now the big problem in a sense if you
wanted to reduce it in Afghanistan
politically is that if I mean if Hamid
Karzai were to be run over by a bus
tomorrow
there is no committee of Pashtun
political leaders who would meet to
choose his credible successor and whose
decision would be regarded as credible
among the broad range of Pashtun
constituents that's the moment
Afghanistan has to arrive at that there
that that this is not all about Hamid
Karzai anymore that it is about parties
political parties that represent diverse
Pashtun points of view that are engaged
in constitutional politics and the
parliamentary elections are very
important in that respect because they
will produce the basis for such politics
but then it has to be actually created
and it'll take some time
but anyway I feel overall optimistic
it's getting colder and colder in here
the woman with the glove speaks to me
does there's there a basis for similar
optimism in Iraq not not visible I think
that the the most interesting I mean
obviously you all understand as well as
I do what's happening in Iraq because I
haven't walked around that insurgency
and you know I've been there once and
really don't have a rich confidence
about the insurgency but I I do have a
couple of thoughts one is that I think
the if you asked the question as I
sometimes try to do what's happening in
Iraq that matters that we understand the
least and in the region in a way as a
result of what's happening in Iraq and I
think it one answer to that is the Shia
revival there is a very powerful moment
in Shia communities in the Arab world
and globally that is at the heart of
what's going to unfold this week in Iraq
the other side of the coin on the other
side of the Sunnis insurgency Baathist
nationalist insurgency is a community's
commitment to this constitutional
process yes out of self-interest but
also as part of a broader regional
revival a moment of enfranchisement for
a community that has felt profoundly
disenfranchised not only in Iraq but
elsewhere in the Gulf I was talking to
somebody who was in Saudi talking to
folks about the these municipal
elections that are due in a couple of
weeks that are you know they don't
amount to a whole lot but they're
something to measure and they're
interesting and he was out in Riyadh
asking who's registering to vote and in
Riyadh the answer was not
many people so far but apparently in the
eastern areas around DeHaan where the
Shia's are prominent registration is
running and very very high rights you
know why well because there's an echo
from what's happening in Iraq and so I I
think that if you try to look at these
elections from an Iraqi rather than an
American point of view those are some of
the things you might observe where it
leads involves more than we want to talk
about tonight but but the violence and
the breadth and complexity of the Sunni
based insurgency has no analogue in
Afghanistan mercifully and it doesn't
look easily addressed by these elections
I'm generally working in the same
territory as this last one but I'm gonna
work a little more on on Saudi Arabia
this next time around
it's me a long time before you see the
fruits of that work yeah that's about as
much as I'm prepared to say thank you
know for your interest yes of our
relationship with the Northern Alliance
from September 10th to September 12
especially considering how much trust we
placed in them in the war on terrorism
in those following months I mean there's
it's been reported that there were
bounties paid to them for prisoners that
they turned over to us who may or may
not have ended up in one time obey and I
was wondering how strong that
relationship was before September 11th
well I think part of what I tried to
document and narrow it was that on
September 10th there was an unresolved
and unfinished well it was resolved but
not in the favor of those on the
Northern Alliance side of the argument
there was an argument about whether or
not the Northern Alliance should be seen
as an ally of the United States or not
and particularly at the CIA in the two
years before September 11th a forceful
case was made from the working-level not
always made at the leadership level that
we really ought to choose sides in this
Afghan war and that was the only serious
way to confront bin Laden and that the
only way to choose sides was to choose
sides with the Northern Alliance
whatever their flaws whatever their
limitations that this was an urgent
matter it required us to choose sides
and these were our natural allies now
they had made that case a number of
times and in the end they were
unsuccessful in persuading either the
cabinet of the Clinton administration or
the cabinet of Bush administration the
first nine months of 2001 to go all in
but because they had been making this
case and trying to develop it in some
detail which involved proposing specific
forms of collaboration with the Northern
Alliance on September 12th it was very
easy to leap to the all right well now
let's try this and it wasn't happening
in a vacuum I mean there were very
specific
it's options that had been developed
about how you would collaborate
militarily with the Northern Alliance
and it was that plan that put the agency
in the lead in the first weeks of
September of September 2001 and was that
that was why Rumsfeld to go back to an
earlier question felt left out because
when the agency marched into the Oval
Office in those urgent hours and days
after September 11th they had something
to say here's a specific plan this is a
plan we've drawn up it's based on own
experience we've been on the ground with
these guys we know what they need to
operate we know who they are here's who
they are here's what we want to do and
the Pentagon because it had held back
from engagement with Afghanistan and
argued against engagement with
Afghanistan wasn't didn't have a
comparable program so that was the
reason that it happened so rapidly was
because it essentially was already drawn
up when September 11th happened
it was an accident really of my
professional life I joined the post as a
reporter in 1985 and as I came to have a
newspaper career I thought very quickly
that I wanted to be a foreign
correspondent the way it works at the
post is it's a very you know it's like a
lot of other places very competitive to
try to get a foreign correspondents job
and so when you want to apply you have
to essentially declare that you're
willing to go anywhere so that's what I
did I said that I was going to go
anywhere anytime you know and so in the
course of being appointed to that staff
I thought I was going lots of different
places and in fact not to tell a boring
story about myself but it was kind of a
moment when and I was still am married
had young kids and my wife is very
adventurous one was willing to apply
basically blank sheet of paper but we
had been told we've been led to believe
in the course of this application
process that we were going first we were
going to South Africa then we were going
to Poland and I was called down to a
meeting in Washington we were living in
New York right on the cusp of our making
our final commitments and I go into a
meeting with my boss and he starts
talking to me about okay you're gonna
adhesive this how the moving works and
these are the logistics and so forth and
about 20 minutes into conversation I
realized that he was assuming that I was
going to India which had never been
mentioned by anyone at any stage along
the way and I didn't want to seem like
reluctant to go or sort of like I had
any second thoughts about going to
because they seemed to have already made
the appointment but I asked if I could
just like take 10 minutes just have a
break and I went out and I called home
and said it was okay so that's how I
went and when I was there
Afghanistan was a big part of what the
Washington Post was interested in that
part of the world and I became very
interested in it as I traveled in
Afghanistan and discovered it from
through my own experience I just became
more and more involved in the region and
you know I have to say we were just back
in India for Christmas and I think South
Asia is just one of those places that
for some people it just kind of takes
and never really let's go and I've now
worked just about everywhere in one way
or another and this is still the place
that I feel the most involved in as you
can undoubtedly tell Israel has provided
popular support
how has America's relationship with
Israel provided popular support for
jihadism around the world well I mean
obviously the unresolved conflict
between Israelis and Palestinians is an
essential part of the context in which a
substantial part of radical of Islamic
radicalization occurs and so I don't
think you can sort of say oh well it's a
sidebar it's context what's interesting
about bin Laden I think though is that
he has never really been very seriously
interested in the israeli-palestinian
conflict even rhetorically he came to it
quite late and his own engagement with
it was you know was almost like a
speechwriter started to put it into his
remarks after a certain point he did
have one personal connection in his
relationship with a bill Azam during the
1980s Abdullah Azzam
Palestinian Muslim brother who is the
founder of a precursor organization of
al-qaeda and so it's not as if he wasn't
acquainted with the issues and he did
advocate for American boycotts and anti
Israeli boycotts in the 1980s as part of
his speech making so I mean to be fair
to him you know he he did speak about
the issue but as he independently even
early but as he independently built up
al-qaeda after his arms assassination in
1989 and as he defined al-qaeda's global
campaign he moved increasingly away from
rhetorical or other concerns involving
the israeli-palestinian conflict it's
notable that to date so far as we know
no cells that we would strictly call
al-qaeda have even attacked Israeli
targets
you know part because the targets are
very hard and whenever they've scouted
them they've basically backed off
Zawahiri and his memoir writes about how
they ended up bombing the egyptian
embassy in Islamabad in 1995 he sent his
team down and first mission was hit the
Americans they looked at the embassy is
said it's too hard to hit they said okay
well then hit the Brits they looked at
the embassy they said it's too hard to
hit and they said okay well then look at
the Egyptians and they said well that we
can do and I think with the Israelis
that you know occasionally they've
they've kind of come off of targets but
I've been Laden's concerns are Saudi I
mean bin Laden I think it has to be
understood as a as a sort of a Saudi
global jihadist and and I think that the
groups around him the Egyptians the
Algerians the Yemenis and others who
have made up the Chechens the Uzbek so I
mean those who have made up the sort of
heart of his hard core whether in the
Soudan phase or in the afghan phase have
been by comparison to other Arab radical
populations relatively disinterested in
the israeli-palestinian conflict and
also one other thing you know after all
Palestinian operate aspirations even
Hamas is aspirations have in some
important respects national aspirations
they are seeking a nation-state and bin
Laden is an interested in nation-states
except in some redrawn 7th century map
sense he's interested in something else
and so all of this complexity of local
politics and and the bargains that
seeking national status require don't
interest him thank you very much for
your attention I'm signing I guess
thank you very much and we're gonna
start the site Steve call is a former
managing editor for The Washington Post
and served as the papers South Asia
bureau chief from 1989 to 1992 he won
the Pulitzer Prize in 1994 explanatory
journalism ghost wars is published by
Penguin get information online at
penguin com